we're standing on London's Millennium
Bridge bridge that crosses the Thames
from the north bank the South Bank in
Shakespeare's time this bridge didn't
exist but there was a another large
bridge London Bridge which doesn't exist
now any longer not very far from here
that you could have walked across to get
to the south bank of the Thames many
people would have done that but many
people to go to the theatre who also
would have paid a boatman to take them
across the river to the south bank
London was a very big city in
Shakespeare's time behind me isn't
Paul's Cathedral designed by Sir
Christopher Wren after the fire of
London in the 17th century that
Cathedral didn't exist in Shakespeare's
time but there was another more ancient
medieval cathedral that did and that was
destroyed and replaced by Sir
Christopher Wren's great building London
in Shakespeare's time was a very large
city was one of the largest cities in
Europe along with Naples and Paris and a
few others and everything in
Shakespeare's career depended upon the
fact that there was a very very large
population here
it's what supported the entertainment
industry the enormous Nampa theaters
like the globe where Shakespeare and his
company performed and the competing
venues as well London was the magnet
that drew people from all over the
country
in Shakespeare's lifetime and of course
it drew Shakespeare here Shakespeare was
born in the provincial town of
stratford-upon-avon but came here to
make his fortune and in doing so he did
what many thousands of other people did
in this time leaving their their homes
and coming to London in hope of finding
something here some money some career
some fulfilment many people found death
instead of delight London was a very
dangerous place there was a high
incidence of plague there was a high
violence rate by our standards but it
nonetheless remained the magnet
for thousands tens of thousands of
people in Shakespeare's time the city
was had a mayor and a group of city
authorities who tried to keep control
over this enormous this enormous mass of
people they weren't happy about the
theater they weren't happy about many of
the forms of entertainment of Londoners
love but they couldn't completely
control them because they didn't control
the entire city they controlled much of
the area that lies behind me but the
south bank of the river where
Shakespeare's theater was located was
less in their control and so we have an
organization in which we have a powerful
city behind me we have a court which was
located in this direction where the
Queen had her principal palaces and also
with Parliament would have met and in
this other direction we had the
notorious the famous and sinister Tower
of London which you can almost see from
here and in which prisoners those
accused of treason would have been taken
to meet their ends these are locations
that have some real force in
Shakespeare's imagination the city
behind us where the riders like Jack
Cade and the others go rampaging through
the streets the court where the Queen
and her court glittering courtiers met
and the sinister Tower of London all of
these places inhabited Shakespeare's
imagination Shakespeare is a global
artist his presence is worldwide
he's the possession of all of us whoever
we are whatever language we speak
wherever we live but he's also an artist
who came from a particular place and
from the late 16th and early 17th
century in England and not only in
England but he had his career here in
London the greatest city in the realm
and to understand something of
Shakespeare we have to go back and forth
between the sense of the universal power
of this remarkable artist and the
particular location the particular world
that he came from and on which he drew
so powerfully so we'll be doing in these
modules is to try to convey a sense both
of the largest frames in which you can
understand Shakespeare but also of the
particular circumstances from which he
came and upon which he drew